[Music]
whatever welcome back to Saint Louis
it's lovely to see you here thank you uh
I checked video and your rating is 26
12. currently and you were of course
over 2700 at some point how do you keep
such a high level
I used to keep a higher level more
higher than that
okay I don't know I used to play on
higher level of course yeah and this was
but also that time I mean I I did a lot
of work yeah just I was working on
everything on chess openings now also
sometimes but somehow whenever you're
over 50 it's already more difficult yeah
you have some other goals in in your
life and episode that it's not like I
would not say that I don't even know
that this is I-12 till the truth I
didn't know that it's such a lull oh I'm
sorry
for me it's still a very high rating and
what are you and what are your goals you
mentioned that after 50 you have
different goals can you change no you
just note that like you already enjoy
your life you don't spend that much time
on chess
and you already normally if you are like
something like this you all those you
lose motivation actually when I was
young I remember that just you should
play and you should win and you make
everything for that
both preparing and during the game and
now I see you lose yeah this like side
this this part of but still yeah still
of course I mean nobody likes losing so
if we come here we try to do our best
it's clear but of course something
something is lost
it's completely different whenever you
are young let's say 20 or something like
this
so this tournament is kind of new for
you did you make any particular
preparation for it or you try to work as
you would work before mostly physical
preparation
because
yeah it's already difficult again
because of of your age
just mostly this some chess some chess
but not more yeah again whenever you are
young you can actually skip that because
you are your fit normally
but now it's already some some some some
problems here already uh and so yeah
physically yeah I did I mean going to
gym and making some like exercises
everything like this chest like already
like um some seconds you already have it
right yeah Alexander shavalov also
mentioned and then actually he send us a
video saying that he's focusing on on
physical progression more than chess and
probably this is the one thing we can
see who's gonna handle better I guess
and how how are you feeling about the
tournament in general about your
opponents
he was very interesting a great
tournament again this was a very
pleasant experience last year I mean I
knew that there is such a tournament but
uh I mean you should be 50 yeah to take
part here so that was great last year
and of course this year I expect also
um I mean very very good opposition of
course uh it's it's it's not easy I mean
it's not easy it's it's very tough and
last year it was also very tough and
this playoff with fifth actually five
players we played the playoff was very
tense actually this year they changed
this because last year I remember after
the minute left of the last round I was
just totally exhausted and playing this
playoff after that was very difficult
but now I see that this year they
changed everything and this is of course
great you can have rest after that and
on the next day you play playoff
so they're always improving and of
course
this is this is great of course this is
Eric glad to hear that and good luck
with the tournament thank you very much
[Music]